[Music]
I'm Josh Welsh president of film
independent and welcome to a very
special evening with Emily Blunt I'm I'm
going to be very brief to hold myself
back from gushing but I just want to say
all of us at film independent are such
huge fans of of Emily and her work and
we could not be happier uh and more
grateful to have her here tonight and to
be able to celebr great her incredible
body of work and um I won't go into a
long list of credits but I will mention
things like um uh Mary Popp and Returns
sario the edge of tomorrow um there was
a fantastic show that she was on last
year called the English on Amazon which
if you haven't seen I highly recommend
so many incredible performances and
really it's an honor to to be here
tonight uh to celebrate her career um I
think a lot of of you are probably film
independent members so I won't do a
whole song and dance about that but if
you're not a member film independent we
are an organization based here in La
that believes we we love movies and the
the wildly talented people who make them
the good ones and uh if if we're an Open
Access membership organization we
produce the spirit Awards an award show
it's a week or so before another uh
award show that happens uh in town maybe
affiliated with this building um and if
you'd like to vote on the winners of the
spirit Awards just joined film
Independent by December the
18th um with that the other incredibly
exciting element of tonight is Emily is
going to be in conversation with an
incredibly talented filmmaker who we are
also huge fans of at film independent
and I will just
say
Chicago Memoirs of AA Mary Poppins
returns please join me in welcoming the
extremely talented Rob
[Applause]
Marshall wow this is great look at all
these people thank you um I have to say
this is such a joy for me to be here
because this is one of my favorite
people on the planet I adore her so much
um we're such great friends but also I'm
you know she's gonna hate me for saying
this but I'm G to say it anyway she's
one of the greats she's one of the
greates and um it's a short list it's a
short list and she's on it I mean it's
so you know it might seem a little early
for her to have a career retrospective
like this tonight but when you see
already at this age the range the
Exquisite work the
breathtaking um infusion of humanity she
brings to every role you will see that
that um you know it's okay that we're
having this tonight because it's it's
it's time um I'd love for you before we
bring her out just to take a look at
some of this Exquisite work which we'll
talk about this evening I'm so thrilled
to be
here right oh my gosh how great were
those
clips I mean for me you see the range is
extraordinary em it just is
extraordinary you look at that and you
think what can't you do what have you
not done and this is when I was saying
before that you're one of the greats and
I truly mean that you know when you
think of kathern Hepburn and rosin
Russell I know and we know each other
well and Maggie Smith right and Merill
right oh you can't not all of them not
all of them all of them that's that's
your that's your league that's who you
are do do people know that I hope people
know that that's where that's what you
are when you see the range up there when
you see you move from and this is fun
because we get to talk about this now
get to talk about all the different
movies and and the range and it it it
it's it's kind of extraordinary and is
it
something we'll talk about it for sure
but is it something that is conscious
for you like to do different things have
different yes experence I mean yes I
think I look for that
um Terror of the unknown maybe every
time um and what that feels to put your
feet to the fire every time and do
something that might be out of character
or or left of center or um unreachable
in some way at first glance you know I
think I like to feel
that um and and to try not to repeat you
know well what's consistent about
everything you do for me is that there
is a Humanity a
relatability we see ourselves through
you and it's so honest it's what every
actor dies to have to find that kind of
Honor honesty and truth and what you do
and and you know it's it it sometimes
you know people see it and don't see
fully what it is it's the hardest thing
to do a I'm you know I'm GNA go a little
out of order tonight just a little bit
because because well just because I real
well I just I want to start with
Oppenheimer okay is that okay
yeah well it's fresh well it's fresh um
it certainly is fresh I will say it's
one of the most searing astounding
performances I've ever
seen it just is because because you are
like a
laser it you know it's not like there's
tons of screen time you come on and I
mean now I'm gonna drop a name because I
was with her last night um I was with
Merl Streep last night and I mean not
with her with
her I was having dinner with Marl and
your ears were burning because we were
talking about you and we were saying she
was just she just said um she's
overwhelmed by your performance in that
film she wrote me the most heart
stopping email about it because she
feels it deeply and she knows she knows
and you know when you I mean it's such a
it's such a complicated layered part
because she's so brilliant this woman
that you play and she's so um
damaged and and crying for help I mean
Merill said you know it's happens to the
women of that era that's right they're
pushed into the kitchen or wherever they
were you know pushed aside you know from
what their Brilliance is that's right
how did you first of all how did it come
to you how did that film come to you
well
um I got a a call that Chris Nolan
wanted to meet you know and I thought do
I have a jetpack to get there as quickly
as possible cuz I was just so excited to
meet him and a bit intimidated probably
because he
is sort of that tremendously
intimidating brain that you think he
will have and will that materialize in a
sort of rather cold person and he was
the opposite he was warm and
lovely and funny and sort of loves a
gossip and you're
like you know it's just amazing it's not
what you expect and so we talked for um
an hour or so and then in the most
understated way which is just his way he
goes uh you know I'd like you to play
the part of kitty Oppenheimer if you'd
like to have a look then you know I'd
love you to do it and I was
like I just didn't even know I was
getting an offer like on that it was
just amazing so I read this
extraordinary pulse racing script um and
for those of you who' have seen it it it
how it plays is how it was
written the extraordinary intercutting
and interwoven narratives and um the way
he was able to it's like he loves the
physicality of film and the fact that
you were able to see
visually these uh chaotic Visions in
Killian's brain and like it was just so
extraordinary and he's able to actually
like photograph unharnessed energy that
would potentially destroy the world we
live in I mean it was was just
staggering and I think maybe because
Chris is such a brilliant filmmaker we
forget what an extraordinary writer he
is you know and it blew me away he we
talked a little more about the part and
then I think very much like you you know
he he loves actors he's he loves them
he's so curious about what you might do
and I remember that with you in your
hands in your hands he knows this is a
smart man well I think he just he he I
think probably what happens with Chris
Nolan is he goes after his first choice
and everyone says yes so it's like his
um his scripts I don't know if you guys
knew this are written on red paper
apparently you can't photocopy red paper
really something to think about oh I got
to get some I didn't think they sell
that at Staples I haven't seen red paper
anywhere so he writes on red paper and
Downey always said he feels like it's
like a kind of hypnotic color so
everyone says yes I was like no say yes
because it's Chris Nolan but um I loved
her I thought she
was so powerful so
fiery all sharp
edges but I I'm always interested in the
shadow of someone's life like why do
they become that way and like Merill was
saying to you last night you know I have
so much empathy for those women who were
meant
for colossal intellectual ual Endeavors
and got squandered at the ironing board
and fested with frustration and regret
and um I think she drove herself
insane in the isolation and loneliness
of Los Alamos of course she was going to
resort to these kind of crutches that
she did and apparently the oppenheimer's
threw um dinner parties but there was no
dinner it was just martinis that was it
it was just Martin cigarette that sounds
like my kind of um but so I mean to me
me when I see it it's it's it's you're
like an Olympian because you because you
have this it's so economical and when
you're on screen you have to go right
there I mean it happens right there in
the moment it's not like you're building
up to it it's h it happens and and and
it's such a I mean to come into the film
like that the way that you do it's so
brutally honest it's just beautiful to
watch it is
masterful masterful and not even like
just discussing the interrogation scene
at the end where we see you
transition from you I mean you know from
so vulnerable and so you know not
together well just such a wonderful
scene you know and in many ways like a
great setup because you've got a
character who's deteriorated so much and
has lost so much dignity and has become
so volatile and sort of
unpredictable that you maybe think she's
going to choke there in the room you all
we're all on pins and needles we're yeah
because we love you see this is this is
what I just want want to say about your
work it you you love you no matter what
you do I love
me but it's true em you bring that out
in people we it's you you you're we we
can see ourselves through you how do you
prepare for something like that like
that scene you were just describing that
like how so it's the day of so what
happens I mean we
actually we shot the wides the night
before and you know sometimes those
scenes are a bit of a stagger through
and you're like sort of marking it but I
felt at that point that set had become a
very well-oiled machine and the thing
that had been helpful to me as a
character was watching all of these
people come in and testify and not stand
up for him wow so I think I'd seen all
of these people come in and just drag
him across the coals and I love that
Killian Murphy so much I I love him so
deeply he's so
extraordinary and as a human being as a
person but in this part and I'd seen
this man become a shell of his former
self even as I sat there mainly like out
of focus for most of them out of focus
Chris golden for most of the
testifying so I'd sort of seen Killian's
Oppenheimer just uh crumble
into dust really and I think that was
helpful to me so by the time I got up to
do my scene and it's probably because
Jason Clark is the most unbelievable bad
guy ever in that he's such a bully and
he's so brilliant um
that maybe by the time it was time to do
the scene I just wanted to rip his face
off and it was really great and and then
on the day um you know and again Chris
is so understated like there's never
this sort of
ceremonious this is a big scene sort of
energy on set it's like all right we got
the camera up yeah ready okay M yeah
good okay and it's just
really non-chaotic and just wonderful in
that way so we were ready to do it and
then Jason said I think I'm going to
move my chair in really close to her and
I think I thought that was a really cool
move and it also created a reaction in
me because I found it like sort of toxic
misogynistic move you know to try and
physically intimidate you and and it
really got my back up you know I mean
the thing is it's it's you know and this
is so true of what you do you never show
off for show off sake and we've seen
those performances big
time I have and I'm telling you talk
tell
them well it's just us that we can but
but I feel like you just land it you're
and this is so it's just and I've
witnessed this as a your director you
just come in it's so immediately in the
groove it is so honest and so truthful
immediately and I've seen actors
literally say to you I don't understand
how you're doing that like I'm searching
for it finding it looking for it trying
the next take and you're just there and
that's what I mean by an Olympian I
think of you that way you're in there
you you you come in you are prepared you
but but also at the same time it's so it
feels so spontaneous it's this
incredible masterful thing you do and no
one does it m but I will say it is it's
it's any kind of spontaneity is is
only um only has space for that kind of
thing when you have a director who's
curious ious you know and interested and
trusts you and wants to see what else
you have and what's in your bag of
tricks and not every director does that
you know some some can make you freeze
up a bit Well here here's what I love
about and this is true of all the
performances we'll talk about this
evening but you know you paint outside
the lines like I you give every color
you like you use every single color in
the paint box so if you're supposed to
be this kind of person we see other
colors we see all the colors but I feel
you know and that's very nice as you can
say I mean you you know me Rob and it's
it's she hates this so much this is
horrible for her you will never have so
much smoke blown up your ass that you
will by Rob Marshall I mean I didn't
need the umbrella on Mary Poppins I
would have just flown like truly I mean
and he would do it also on the god mic
we had that we had on set in front of
the British crew it was my favorite
thing who were just you know the like
we're just we don't do this right and he
would get on the mic and be like M it is
just incredible and you see the British
crew were
[Laughter]
like well it's so easy with you that's
the thing it's so simple I can't even
remember what I was going to say but
like um well it's listen it it it's true
but it's true and it's so easy to call
it out about you know the the the range
of every moment I just no moment is
about one thing no no not no no one
sentence just about one but there are so
few actors that do that they play
equality and they play it from beginning
to end and that's they're sort of doing
their thing name them who do
it okay here comes the no um but it
really but that's what's amazing about
you always surprise you always surprise
me and it's so human and so truthful
people are surprising I think I'm always
surprised by people all the time and
and one moment is about a myriad of
different things and so I think it's my
job to try
to
um play that really because you know
people will say something or they'll ask
you a question and it won't necessarily
be as direct as as the question it will
be about other things and you see that
and you use that that's the genius and
um and congratul ation on your Golden
Globe nomination and your critic's
choice nomination which and there's and
there's so much more to come this thing
okay um I I'm gonna jump back now just a
few years let's go way back just for a
moment I just wan to I mean it's such an
auspicious beginning to your career to
be in the royal family directed by Sir
Peter Hall on the West End playing Judy
Den's granddaughter in the royal family
so how does that how does that that
happen it does I mean how does that
happen how do you get how's that your
debut I mean I I was very lucky because
you know um and it's a terrible thing to
say as a English actor I I didn't train
you know which is I was so embarrassed
about saying in England because it was
like a big no no like everyone went to
drama school and um I landed my uh UK
agent when I was 17 and he came to see a
school play I did and so when I turned
I he tried to get me into audition for
Peter Hall and the casting direct said
no he's only seeing people who've been
to drama school and Roger chartas was
like no trust me she's she's great like
you've got to see begged and begged and
begged and begged no no no no no for the
longest time and eventually he agreed to
see me and so I audition for Peter Hall
and and were you intimidated I mean very
very you know and how was Judy with you
unbelievable really
a godsend really like the launch
into trying to do it the right way you
know because the business is so
overwhelming and maybe the worst thing
you can do is take it too seriously all
the time and she's so joyful and she's
so funny and naughty and would go out of
her way to make me laugh on stage like
every night and we would be crying with
laughter on stage and corpsing and it
was just heaven and she was gracious and
kind to me and she'd bring me into her
dressing room every night and like
Johnny Depp would be there and Pierce
broen would be there and I was like like
it was just so amazing you know I think
she saw kindred spirit I think she saw
someone oh she was so so wonderful to me
yeah so then what's interesting is your
first sort of major film I would say Is
My Summer of Love yeah and have you any
have people seen that film it's it's
it's pretty extraordinary it really is
it's extraordinary are you here
like it's like shocked when people have
seen it I mean it is a beautiful film
great pav pikovski who's incredible
incredible I mean the it's a complicated
movie and it's um and your character is
incredibly dense you know I I I mean it
it was surprising she kind of a nasty
girl she's nasty and she plays games and
she does those kinds of things but it's
very layer but you know that I mean I
always kind of I kind of based her on
there were those girls you guys know
there girls in high school and there's
like a light around them and you just
want to be a part of their world and
they're not always very nice yeah but
you I was obsessed with some girls in my
class I was like wow like and you didn't
know at that age it's like you didn't
know if you wanted to be them or be with
them or like it was just they were so
magnetic and so I she was sort of based
on a couple of girls I went to school
with and and liked toying with people
there was something exciting about well
you understood it and once again even in
the clip you know you see it's you're
you bring humor to it too you that's
what I mean by finding all the colors
it's so consistent in all your work even
then and it's a brave I mean it's ve
very brave very brave I mean for what
you were able so you must have felt you
could trust I mean here you are really
in your first lead role really and and
caring a film I mean I was very
scared uh working like that it was all
improvised
even the audition like when I went to
audition for
pavl um it was the scariest audition
because it I knew it would be an
improved
audition I went in there and he's
amazing pavl and he goes okay so I want
you to look out the window and uh you
see your dad and he's like his
secretary and I was like okay and he
goes and you got to like get very very
mad like very angry and then cry and
then pretend the whole thing is a joke
and laugh and I was
like and he was like okay go and and it
was so scary you know it was just so
scary to have to do it and I I remember
thinking I'd completely blown it and and
then he he asked me to come back and
read with Natalie who played the other
girl who was so extraordinary and but
the whole film it was so free-spirited
it was
so i' just come from English television
you know I hadn't worked like that and
we would sometimes wait for magic hour
for the most perfect light it was just
the most artistic thing I'd been a what
about the size of performance I mean
coming from theater and how did you know
film I mean to me well I didn't I mean I
I I remember the first TV thing I did
was this um TV show called budika about
budika the warrior Queen I was like
covered in blue WOD all the time with
bad braids but um uh we shot in Romania
I remember I was doing my first scene
ever on film with this lovely actor his
name was Gideon what was his last name
Gideon he was so nice and I was really
projecting you know and he just goes um
you said that boom is you can whisper
and it will hear you and I was so
embarrassed and because I just come from
you know yelling so but you learn it
quick I mean that's what's great you're
instinctive and that's what you see and
you won the evening standard award for
most promising newcomer and that was
really exciting Emma that I mean you
just knew that you were heading in that
direction and I'm I'm just going to jump
to um a television piece that you did
but it it got you so much a claim and
you won you a Golden Globe which was
Gideon's daughter which is have you seen
that it's Exquisite her work is so
beautiful and it's really a a tale of
forgiveness I would say in a way you
know forgiving the sins of your your
father your father and and and you sang
in that I mean the one of the reasons I
found out about that is when I did my
detective work to see I believe could
sing you know because there's not a lot
of you know you're like who you know
you're looking when I'm doing a musical
like and um it's scary to yes but what's
beautiful about that and this is
interesting about about singing in film
because you know people sing and then
there are people that act and then there
people that don't know how to put those
two things
together and what's so incredible about
that song in that television piece is
that
you are you it's your whole relationship
with your father is in that song I mean
I think it was called my papa or
something like that some song and and
but but but you knew how to deliver
that how did you I mean a lot of people
can't do that M how do you do that well
the S I mean Stephen poov was really you
know he he said you need to sing the
entire thing directly at him and there
was so much animosity between me this is
Bill NY by the way Bill NY who's just so
extraordinary actor amazing and just
such a wonderful person and so yeah I
had to sort of shoot daggers at him
while I sang it and um but there's also
love in your eyes too see that's the
thing it's this kind of was so torted
the relationship and the the the the
idea when you start to lose touch of
your child or your teenager and how
scary that is for a parent and when you
can't access them anymore and um I think
a lot of parents go through that when
they kids hit the teenage years and they
lose them for a second it's terrifying
and um yeah it was it was sort of a
heartbreaking moment and I did love
doing that scene but as you know I
avoided auditioning for you for a while
because I was so scared to sing in front
of you which is ridiculous no but you
especially because I think no yes you
and I remember Rob knows this that when
he was auditioning people for nine I
said no and I remember my agent Chris is
sitting here and Chris yeah Chris I'm
going to kill you for that one and and I
said no and Chris I don't know how you
got this memo but Chris had heard that I
was supposed to bring my jazz shoes no
this is such a lot and I was like Over
My Dead Body like that I I would rather
drink bleach than do that I was like I
don't want to do so Nicole kimman
brought her Jes I mean what you talking
she it she nailed it and she was
amazing so when I told Rob that Rob was
like Jaz she jzz shoes okay so I don't
know I was like no I don't want to do it
and then by the time into the woods came
around I said no again and Chris called
me and Rob had called you and he said
she's coming in yeah and you're forgiven
Chris big and you're forgiven Chris but
Rob said she's coming in I'm looking for
um actors who can kind of sing not
singers who can kind of act I'm looking
for Emily Blunt is what I was looking
for 100 100% yes it's true but I was
very scared to audition for you but I'm
so grateful that I did well it I mean
for me um it was Earth changing because
you know when you when you have an actor
that you love and I loved your work and
I we had met a few times and yeah so and
loved each other right away like old
friends crazy that's so weird but you
have chemistry with everybody so that's
just how it goes but I just remember
when
you when you started to sing it was
moments in the the woods what you saw
here it was in the wrong key it did not
sound good sounded better then it was
but it was all there it was a full
performance and I couldn't believe it
and I started to cry I started to cry
because I couldn't there was the movie
right there was the movie you know
that's what I don't think people
understand you know these you take these
little baby steps and you're looking for
the film and in walks the film in walks
the story it's the story of the baker's
wife really and it's your story and
there it was and I we had a movie and I
just thought I'm gon to work for with
this woman for the rest of my life and I
really felt that and I still feel that
you know that Rob was uh I think the
second person I told that I was pregnant
um my husband first I I I think John
might have heard first um but he rob had
cast me in into the words I didn't
realize I was pregnant when I auditioned
for you so
I got the part and then I was like oh my
God what am I going to do and I'm also
supposed to be playing this childless
woman was like Baron Baron Baron poor
baren woman um so I waited till I was
sort of nine weeks 10 weeks just hoping
everything would be okay with the baby
and I called Rob and I went um I need to
tell you something and he
goes you're having a baby and I went uh
yes I am and he immediately went it's
not going to be a problem you can hide
behind James Gordon and every tree in
the woods and the cow and the anything
else we can front of you apron and it
was fine it was great you don't see it
at all yeah well towards the end you do
but but I remember doing that scene uh
the the scene that precedes that one
with Chris Pine and we'd rehearsed it
when I was like three months pregnant
and by the time we shot it I was seven
and a half months pregnant and there's a
bit where he does this like big dip with
me and I just was like I hope you've
been doing some squads because there's
like 20 more pounds coming down on your
quads right now but um you had such you
were amazing with
him he was so funny and that and you
were so great with him that scene was
just Divine and just working with it and
he was in awe of you as we all are you
know he's like I remember him saying how
do you do this you know because he
tortures himself like how am I going to
do this and you were and you just I
remember his vocal warm-ups in the room
next to mine and I just be trying to
take a pregnant nap I'd be like shut up
he would literally be like like all day
every was so scared so funny and and and
your experience with sa time oh I mean
how amazing to have had that experience
very scary when he came to the recording
studio and that's he that's when he
wanted to be there he wanted to make
sure as we were putting it down yes and
we had worked on it aot lot but he you
know he he came and he really was he you
know he listens he doesn't even look at
you right he doesn't look he he's
hearing it and and feeling it and and
sometimes he looks a bit tortured by it
you know which is quite scary I I mean I
don't know if I ever told you that when
I said that I was going to cast you um
he had he had um say over you and James
and Merill and his and his that was sort
of like what he in his he did tell me I
guess this did I tell you in his like
whatever in his contract
so um he said these words
hallelujah thank God can you imagine if
he went
[Laughter]
ooh okay now I'm just gonna jump to the
devil War's P
sure because I don't know about you guys
but when I saw that film this is what I
thought to myself who is that
this is a brilliant
hilarious great actor I I mean I I just
thought it doesn't get better than that
it's so I mean it's just to me you take
the movie and it put it in your pocket
because that's what it was for me 100%
for me and so what was how did that all
come about I mean did you have to read
or oh Goda I mean I wasn't no one knew
who I was right and a thing and I I was
auditioning for a different thing at Fox
I remember I was going in to read for
something else and then I was really
late for the airport and so maybe I was
just sort of frantic and chaotic which
might have worked for the character and
they said hey would you ever read for
this other thing we're doing it's just
this little thing with Merl street I was
like what um so uh I
read one of the scenes I think that one
so funny I think it was that one and and
I was quite chaotic and then ran almost
missed my flight and then got a call a
week later from David Frankle and he
said look I would cast you but the
studio was wondering if you could wear
something more stylish in your you're
kidding me no to be fair I was wearing
like a hoodie in jeans when I auditioned
for it so I I pulled together something
that I thought looked
fairly Chic I don't know it probably was
awful and I read for it again in London
and then he called me the next day and
he said I want you to do it and I cried
oh my God I was in my mom's house and I
walked out into the garden to take the
call and I cried was it life-changing
that film lifechanging yeah I mean the
the experience was lifechanging it
was Heaven that movie was heaven we had
a party it was just you can tell it was
just exquisitly fun and it played to all
your strengths too I mean that's what I
loved about it I love I just love that
you you know it's your vulnerability
that's what I love in all your work well
I think the thing with her especially is
that on the page she came across is you
know she was so aeric and so cutting and
I thought it might be funnier to play
her desperate you know I think that
desperation is funnier than someone who
just but then we got to really really
see those comic jobs that's what we got
to see and then you go wait wait a
minute is there no end to the range uh
is there no end to the range for me
no because because I mean already you're
doing that so it it's extraordinary and
you were nominated for a baa and a
Golden Globe for that as well which was
extraordinary work that will live
forever time of my life that it live
forever it was the best it was the best
um can I just ask just quickly about
Charlie Wilson's War because I know it
was a smaller role but because it was
Mike Nichol's last film yes so I'm
always curious you know because he's our
God all director is he's our god what
was that like with him you know he was
truly one of the first big champions of
my career because I auditioned for him
while I was still filming devil West PR
so no one had seen devil was Prada and
it was kind of like when Prada came out
things changed quite a lot but I
auditioned for him right at the tail end
of that shoot and he still cost me
really yeah so it was really meaningful
to me and then I was it was so surreal
to be sort of crawling o all over Tom
Hanks and my underwear and i' like grown
up watching him it was so odd now but I
mean I love Tom Hanks but it was so I'm
sure he was a gentleman I'm sure he
really was yeah yeah he was but but is
that intentional like for instance I
mean it's interesting when you start
carving a career now you're in a
position where maybe you have a little
Choice yeah little choice right it
starts that that's what's so interesting
you know you hit with something that's
so big and everybody goes whoa yeah you
know and I mean we all did um then
there's then do you start saying well
okay now this is something different
this is like you were saying before that
this is okay now I get to mix it up a
little yeah I feel there's like a
there's a pattern that sometimes
happens I think maybe you'll remember
this Chris as well like after Prada I
think I got offered a lot of sort of
British people and I was like I
can do other things you know so I yeah
it was cool to play something sexy and
uh physical like that in Charlie
Wilson's and and it's always been a
conscious decision to not get
pigeonholed um or or trapped in a
lane but that's but that takes a lot of
guts because a lot of people are fearful
about will they work and and to sort of
say no I'm gonna I trust myself and I
see that in your work you know it's you
you you see the trust in yourself and
you know it's it's always kind of
Staggering to me anyway so I I will say
that was that to me was exciting to see
you and it's sort of a whole different
light you know I mean that and that um I
I I just want to Now sort of jump to a
movie that I adore um and it and for
many reasons but it's the young
Victoria and the young Victoria is about
young Victoria Queen Victoria and it's
your movie so that's a different thing
on a different scale
and what's sort of incredible about that
film for me is that you you think of
Victoria in a certain way you know
corseted and kind of the queen which is
exactly opposite of how you played her
how did you approach that where did that
come from that idea I mean I jean Mar
valet the great je who we lost which is
the saddest thing
he he was
incredible cuzz he kept saying to
me
um he was French Canadian and he was
like she's a rock star she's she forget
the bun W what a great forget the bunnet
she's a rock star you know and and a and
a rebel and he would play Rolling Stones
on set and he would play the atmosphere
on set was so kinetic and so
um such a juer position from the corsets
and the Bonnets and the it was just I
think it was the vibe that that took us
all over and and the realism of playing
it um it's almost like you have to I
feel with a period drama otherwise it
can feel really stuffy just to play
against the costume was that freeing for
you to be able to do that yeah yeah
completely completely and was and and
for you when you were when you know did
you ever think oh I I have to sort of do
the Royal thing it's and and and you
know or was it I'm just going to play
this as a woman yeah I think he was just
really open
to um any thoughts I had and and I
remember we were doing the coronation
scene and the CRA and the throne was
pretty high up and my feet were hanging
off the edge and I said that' be a cool
show you know just to show how young she
was and I just remember that shot he did
of the feet not touching the floor you
know and it was all his open openess and
the Nuance of depicting this little girl
in a job where she is way over her head
and that's really the truth is that she
was thrust into a position as a child
effectively as a 18-year-old where she
was just way over her head see that's
what you do em you always go into the
corners of these characters and find the
vulnerabilities of them so that they're
full and and and so that's when I watch
your work it's so astonishing because
you see see all of the sort of rough
edges yeah you know that's what you do
and I think you look for do you look for
those rough edges search search for them
want want them that's what I think makes
that you so human and that's what I mean
when I say we relate to you you know
what I mean there are people that you
see on film you think oh that's it but
you don't relate to them we are with you
even as young Victoria it was incredible
thank you and a Golden Globe nomination
for best actress so now you're in this
other league right that's exciting yeah
you're a baby I don't know I I I just
think it's just when I think about that
it's just it it it's you know it you see
it coming you see how you were moving
into these I don't know into into
stardom into film stardom and it's true
I know you don't think that but we do
and we see you it's because who do you
want to watch who do you want to be with
who do you who can take you through a
journey and and you can feel for them
and care
I I you know that's what I when I watch
you I care about everything you do I
care about that person because you show
me all of it that's what's so
extraordinary it's extraordinary am I
right it's stunning it's stunning and it
happens in every single thing you do I'm
telling you it's the truth it's the easy
thing to say drink this is so much it's
too many nights this is your life this
is it who's coming out yeah exactly here
they come um then you know now you're
going to laugh about this because I just
I just need to I just need to mention
The Adjustment Bureau for a second stop
it see I'm telling you no it's such an
in joke with me and Matt Damon now truly
it's like we're we're neighbors I don't
know if anyone knew that we live in the
same building we will see each other
around Brooklyn Heights and he'll just
pretend to just do that with a fedora to
me from across the street it's just the
best great and you danced it and but you
know but here's here's what you had with
him and and and it's what we were
talking about before but you have with
everybody is chemistry he's you could
have I mean Matt is like you could have
he's just heaven to have chemistry with
because he's just so easy and relaxed
and wonderful and we we really hit it
off and and he's my friend he's a I know
but you feel it you feel it and it was
kind of in a weird way maybe a little
bit of your entree into the action world
do you know what I mean it's that kind
of that kind of movie yeah you know and
that bigger kind of movie that
bigger budet it felt like a big movie it
felt like and he's yeah when I met Matt
I was like movie
star now all of a sudden now you're
doing those movies that that kind of
movie which is really exciting and and
it's loved right everybody sees it and
it's just well because it's fun it's fun
and and exciting and and mat did press
for Oppenheimer recently and this
journalist came in and he went oh my God
I loved you guys in the attachment
Bureau
ah it was the best it's my favorite when
they get the names wrong it's the best I
did press with Bono for
sakario and I did this movie called The
Wolf Man with Bono you're welcome
everyone um for the wolf man um but a
journalist came in and she went oh my
God I loved you and the wild
man do you correct them or no which is
what's that do you correct them no I I
just laughed so high cuz it also it's
the perfect sort of name for B Del Tor
is just qu the wild man it's just Oh
Heaven it was just heaven for me oh I
love it I love it um so in a way I kind
of feel like at a certain point in this
part of your career you started to
really sort of dig into some comedy work
which is just isn't that joyous to be
honest like that like with you and
McGregor oh and salmon fishing in the
Yemen so is that I mean for me like it's
it's so fun it just feels it just it it
fits you it suits you it's it must have
felt kind of fantastic to I love doing
comedy and I but I love doing comedy
with the right again the right people
the right environment the right director
the ability to throw the kitchen sink at
it and see what might be funny and where
you can be uninhibited I think comedy
needs a lack of inhibition on set I
think I think you need to feel really
trusting and confident and a willingness
to imp Prov and stretch something around
and do you like that do you like being
thrown into something what about
rehearsals how do you feel about
rehearsals don't don't love them unless
it's for a musical MH well you have to
yeah you have no choice because it's you
again again yeah I like it um I think
what I loved working with you is that
and it's the only reason is probably the
only you're the only person who can make
movie musicals in the most extraordinary
way is that you have figured out that
this the songs are extensions of the
scenes and it's just that idea that if
someone can't quite Express themselves
in a scene then they'll sing it and
there's a seamlessness from scene to
song and the reason you rehearse I
realize to with such a kind of
meticulous beautiful approach is so that
you feel that seamlessness like as
people transition into sun so you don't
have that eggy moment of people being
like and here's a song you know and
every the whole audience sort of
tightens with cringe you know and
um which can happen with especially with
movie musicals because it can the face
is the landscape suddenly and you see
you register everything so much more
closely and you don't have that yes the
performative nature of a stage so yes I
I loved it especially on on Poppins that
you know
um
that there was so so much preparation
and so much Freedom therefore on the day
you know well I have to say you know you
need a great actor to be able to make
that transition so so that the so that
the song continues the
scene and we and we shouldn't be aware
that you're singing and I and Rob does
this in amazing thing that's also like
terrifying for actors where we will
rehearse which is heaven you pre-record
the songs knowing what the scene will
look like CU you've rehearsed it for
weeks which is so helpful because then
the song fits into the movie you
pre-record and then on the day you sing
to your track and then he has this
terrifying moment where he goes okay
we're going to do one live and
everyone's like you know and it's
terrifying and so and and then you're
given a little in ear ear wig where you
can hear the score but no one else on
set can it's true so it's a terrible
Acappella version
of that and oh it's horrific can I just
say right now like my hand sweat even
talking about I would say I would say 75
to 80% of that song was live but that's
a talky singing song Maybe yeah but
that's harder I think in a way that's
harder well because you're not just sort
of La launching into excuse us for a
minut I'm not I'm not not having to like
Mariah carry my way through a song No
but I'm saying that you're it's more
like kind of thought processes so yes
but but that kind of thing is so in some
ways harder because you are literally
having to play the scene to a rhythm
yeah you know what I mean do you know
that was the day I remember Steven sine
was um in the recording studio and he
loved it takes two which was the thing
the SE the song I do with James cordon
and I remember he came in when I was
singing moments in the woods and gave me
a note what was it
what was the note he came in and he goes
just just like stop staying on the beat
just throw it away tell me a story tell
me a story see like wasn't interested in
it being musical or perfect or contorted
to I don't know it's just it was amazing
because what he tried he he embodies
himself with each character so that he
writes for that character yeah and every
little pause every little rest has a
reason you know or how it moves through
something because he feels like that's
how the person would speak and talk yeah
but he's interested in the thought
process rather than how musical it is
absolutely it was so cool which is why
some of the great performers of his
musicals aren't singer singers glennis
John's and my music you know what I mean
they're she sings Send in the Clowns but
it's heartbreaking yeah you know great
role for
you great role for
you um another fun Five-Year Engagement
so much fun so funny with Jason seagull
oh my God I you guys love all the weird
ones well cuz we get know because I mean
in this day and age that's what you want
to watch you want to see that and and
lift it and laugh and it's fun and it
was fun I mean that's I mean it must
have been fun to sort of say okay some
comedy work that you get to sort of
really dig into that for yourself I mean
I I I love it I mean it's it's endlessly
fun and especially I mean that was my
also my first experience working with
those guys who they they are writing on
the day it is Nick Stoler Jason every
they they'd be yelling out lines from
behind the camera to try you know and it
was just so spontaneous and Bonkers and
you're okay with that kind of that yeah
I think it's yeah it's great it's great
so it's that I mean some people would
freeze up and would freak but I like
adapting and you you you have to adapt
you have to embrace um different
experiences and I think sometimes the
best movies and certainly where you have
the best chemistry with
someone um usually is born from a
certain chaos for for me in my
experience on set where there's
rewriting happening there's stuff is
spontaneous and alive and energy sort of
bouncing off the walls and you feel like
you're in
um you you're trying to get out of a
safe room or something it's like like
every day is like trying to it's like
that you know that those people do those
um Escape rooms you do Escape rooms and
that's what sometimes the day can feel
like but at the end of the day you've
ended up with a scene that's that's
kinetic it's it's crackling with
something rare and real and and the
especially with comedy I think that's
great because it happens in the moment
does yeah yeah it's great to work like I
know the answer this but I'm going to
ask it anyway okay because I want them
do you watch yourself on the monitor do
you watch never never never I don't like
never because I think you um I mean
maybe for like a a stunt you know yeah
to make sure it's you're doing it right
yeah yeah to make sure you're not
running weird
yeah by the way I mean this was some
advice that Matt Damon gave me that when
he did the born identity he was working
with that amazing actress who' just done
Run Lola run oh wow yeah and she watched
him do a run and she goes um you should
watch
yourself and he was like what do you
mean and and she goes just how you think
you run is not how you run and it's true
it's true it's true like you'll have a
wonky leg or you'll kind of be hunched
or it'll just it won't look great that's
so funny so I I watched myself run and
I'll watch myself do a but I've never
seen you say can I see that take back
can I see that no no no and and I think
it's because I spend the experience of
the film looking out and when you see it
reflected back you it comes back at you
like that and I don't like that any and
it makes you self-conscious then way
well I just said there probably a bit
waste of time and sort of like yeah you
bit self-conscious so there's there's a
trust I mean that takes a lot of because
you have different experiences with
different directors and stuff so the
trust thing is sometimes not easy I
would think not not always easy like
there's sometimes where
I you you know there's some movies you
can't wait to see the back of and
there's some movies that You Weep when
they're done yeah you know but there's
only a few I've had that I've had a
tough time whether it's an ego or an
agenda or or an environment that feels
kind of toxic and and that's not fun not
it's not Life's Too Short yeah do you
watch your films I do do you watch them
I try to watch them twice okay when
would that be films that I haven't
enjoyed like a couple of them that I
haven't enjoyed I haven't ever seen
really yet what I can't oh my God that's
horrible question I can't and I
won't
um uh I will watch them twice because
the first time I'll probably fixate on
stuff and the second time I'll be more
removed and that's a better but I see
you you're such a generous person I mean
maybe one of the most generous people
I've ever met in my life and so I I I
see you see the whole film even when
you're watch you watch the whole film I
tried to which is extra I mean I I don't
even know how you know how you do that I
mean as an actor how you could even
watch a film and well I don't know if I
used to watch films like that I think
it's like the longer you do it and the
more interest I have in the entire all
consuming world of it and I am really
interested in how it's being shot now
and what the emotional Drive of the film
is what's the through line what's the
message what do you want people to feel
and all of it now like the
pre-production the editing I'm really
interested in all of it um and then
you're going to direct
no I've seen what you guys go through
I'm married to one okay that's true I
know that's true maybe maybe at some
point yeah I canbe some it'd be very I
it's natural for you I think um so
what's interesting is with these sort of
next two films in a way it's a totally
different it's a left turn to a
different genre so Looper yeah and then
the edge of tomorrow oh like those two
so now we're in full
sci-fi I mean that's what I mean by
range I mean I don't know anybody who
can do that I mean seriously I no one
well I didn't think I could do it I mean
I barely worked out before Edge of
Tomorrow and you know was one of those
things where they're like you know
you're going to do an action movie and I
was
207 2 and I was like oh it won't take me
long to get into shape and then you're
like oh God like it takes months what
did you do I did six days a week two
workouts a day what for three months and
I did everything from you know weight
training to Krav MGA gymnastics I ran
the UCLA Track those
steps in a weighted vest no shoot me did
your body oh hell I I remember that the
first two weeks I was in so much pain my
body was just killing me and I remember
even brushing my teeth at night like
that I couldn't like thank you so much I
couldn't move my arm I couldn't I would
get out of bed and just like stagger to
the bathroom I mean I was just I I was
in so much pain all the time my muscles
had never worked like that and then all
of a sudden your body does change and it
transforms and your ability became my
capacity physically became so addictive
and then you know you work with Tom Cruz
he really he'll tighten the screws on
everyone when it comes to like what you
think you're capable of and because he
can do everything and wants to do
everything it makes you want to meet him
where he's at wow that's beautiful did
he inspire you to do that completely
completely he's he was so inspiring such
a doll to me so cute oh he's so cute I
loved him and he's um yeah he was was
amazing and and maybe it was my first
experience also where I was brought so
much into the fold and that was another
movie that at times was chaotic like we
were sort of writing the third act as we
went and again sometimes the best movies
they're born out of that that because
it's all happening in the focus it's
like fixing something everybody's
focused on fixing it and that becomes
part yeah and I think I thought it was
going to be sort of boy club and he
brought me into every script meeting
every every single you're so brilliant I
would have you an meeting too but I mean
that was exciting for us to see you do
that do a kickass part there you were
fun I mean and full metal I'm like
yes s the coolest name ever but I
remember the first time they put those
suits on us um my suit weighed
£85 my God it was so heavy that I
started to cry in front of Tom
Cruz like they put it on he's like
looking at me and I was like no it's
just like I wasn't like really expecting
it to be like so heavy and I was like
panicking about seven months of it and
then you just get on with it and it was
it was great and so you surprised
yourself ultimately yeah it was the
hardest thing physically I will ever
ever do in my life was that movie wow I
mean the suits were so heavy that I
would walk from here to there and you'd
be out of breath oh my God and then in
between takes there was such a pava to
take off that they would they had these
like A-frames on set with hooks and
they'd like hang your suit and you just
hang in it like a puppet and so I just
like there's pictures of me and Tom just
like talking hanging in our suits you
know because you just they they take
half an hour to take them off so into
the woods yes and um just to jump on
that for one more second because it was
fun to talk um you know what was
um I mean what was exciting about that
was you know
the whole son of it of course but also
the fact that here you are doing a full
musical and it felt so natural for you
to me it did and and and once you were
in it and doing what did did it feel
natural to you because of you no no no
no no no no it's
time okay it's because of you it's
because you were so
emboldening
interested free excited by actors
weren't interested in Perfection didn't
really care how it sounded it was just
it was just an ex the most
um Buzzy experience for me working with
you and it was imag really magical and
we were such
a we were really were a kind of company
of actors on that you know I mean we did
rehearse and you know and it was so
wonderful to have you with with Merill
again because we saw you in a different
way I mean you've had that experience
with her many times now and a few with
me and two with you yeah I know and she
just she she's in awe of you I mean she
said this to me last night as well she
she's in awe of you and what you do and
how you do it and who you are that's
what I just need to say for just a
minute because you have to understand
that Emily I just have to say this
because it's this is your last nice
thing you're allowed to say no see
that's it it's all the British coming
out and her she hates it so but the
thing is it's just that you know you are
such a as you can see this is who Emily
is there's no there's no there's nothing
you know there's nothing hidden here
it's like this is who you are you are
you are you're such a a true friend a
real person who who was loved by
everybody and especially by women I mean
all of Emily's friends are like major
actors who adore you and you and they
all center around you it's like a you're
like a satellite and they're all they
all come to you because of who you are
and that's that generosity of spirit but
you see I mean and it's a very special
unique thing and that happens and it
doesn't happen because I've worked with
so many women in in in the business and
you just there's something about you
there everyone's attracted to who you
are the truth of who you are the reality
of who you are and all of that plays
into what you bring to the screen I
really truly believe that that's why I
feel like you in a way have see-through
skin you can feel what you're Fe when
when I watch you I feel it and feel so
connected every time that's it I'm going
to cut you off now that's enough that's
enough that's your last nice thing well
you got a Golden Globe nomination for
for that and that was exciting and I was
so thrilled yes it was so happy um and
then and then a complete sort of change
to something that was so brutal and so
rough and so hard with sakario sario
sakario sakario I mean for me that was I
mean I just remember watching with John
and we were just astonished by your work
and that the movie is so astonishing
it's so hard to watch it's so brutal and
once again we're seeing it through your
eyes like you're we're you you know
you're you're part of this and I think I
mean she was such an amazing role
because she
um she's in such an incoherent world
and she has to be as lost and as in the
dark as the audience but you were then
you made that happen for us so we so
we're following all through you and I
think I didn't realize when we were
shooting it just how much was from her
perspective I didn't realize maybe that
there was nothing um portrait about it
it was very much like an interior yes um
Journey for the audience you know
through her eyes and it was all through
her eyes she thrust into this amoral
world and she's a character who's all
about morality and the FBI they they're
held accountable for every bullet that's
fired and she suddenly in a world where
bullets are sprayed and was just so wild
and um friends of mine who know that
world well have all said oh my God
that's the most well-observed
version of that world we've seen and
who's leaked stuff because that's really
how it goes that's really how it goes
like Josh's character the CIA guy and
the flipflops that's based on someone
you w that's like guys I know who have
worked with the CIA they're like that
guy is that's right but it was it was
brutally is what it felt like to I know
and those boys just oh Josh and bonio
are
just the best because because because so
you go through something brutal like
that like that scene where there's a gun
in your throat and then they say cut so
what happens then I mean after a scene
like that you know it was quite an
intense one and there was a big uh I
remember that uh but I mean normally I
don't take the work home with me and we
would have have have levity on set I
know Bono a long time and Josh is you
know heaven and but I remember after
there's a big fight scene with John
Bernthal in it I don't know if you guys
remember if you've seen that scene where
we have this very physical very ugly
very violent fight and we didn't over
choreograph it and we really kind of
kick the out of each other was
terrible and God um I mean John bal's
wonderful and he said like I used to be
boxer my face is pudding you can just
hit me I won't feel it and it's kind of
true but um and I did hit him um but we
finished that
scene and I felt fine and we all went
and got for heas at craft service and we
were like great scene high five you know
and then I went home and I went to bed
and my heart was like oh wow like
couldn't shut off that feeling of panic
and what it is to be completely
overpowered by a guy I was like couldn't
sleep for a week it's a horrible it was
just a horrible I don't think people
understand that you know you have to
live through it you even though you're
acting in as a camera you're living
there's something you are you are living
it yeah you you're in a different part
of your brain when you do stuff like
that so maybe it collects later and then
the emotion came out or something I
think so and there's certain scenes that
will really wipe me out you know and
I'll be tired after them yeah but I do
try not to I I can't work in a tortured
way I don't want to torture myself I
don't want to torture those around me
and I don't want to go home to my
children in a weird state but there are
scenes that are lasting that their
fingerprints can be intense and some of
the sakario scenes had had those I'm
sure and I and and I would think the
girl on the train yeah yeah which
is heavy heavy also I was pregnant with
my second kid on that wow I
know raging alcoholic well I mean it's
amazing you know you're having this care
you're having this amazing career and
you're done at the same time you're also
this extraordinary mother and you're
balancing that how do you like I mean I
I know because I see it in action it's
it's an he's like the uncle to my
children he and John come to us for
Fourth of July every year and my
children call them their funes because
they come with like sacks of candy and
gifts and they and I told the girls I
was seeing you tonight and they wondered
what you were going to bring me because
you just always come Laden with like
aming gifts but um yeah they they adore
you guys well the balance that you
create is is is something extraordinary
to watch too because that's that's a
full-time job and you're a full-time
mother in a most amazing beautiful way
thanks but something like you know when
you get to something like girl in the
the train where you're playing someone
who's basically unlikable in a way do
you I mean and a sort of
unreliable narrator as well yeah so so
and we're seeing it all through her
perspective how do you find your way
into someone like that who is so
diametrically opposed from who you are
it's just it's she's so damaged and so
how are you you know how do you find
your way into that person I mean um if
you guys has ever seen that show
intervention I watched a lot of
intervention to play her because that
show um it's real people with a real
addiction with real trauma with that
quiet desperation of addiction that you
watch and the Damage that um and the
Ripple
effects around them
and it's a traumatic show to watch but
it's such a window into the reality of
it
because um you don't want to be
doing the undignified thing of just
misrepresenting it or misidentifying
what it is to be in the position that
the character was in so I usually go to
a documentary or something like that to
really see what that's about and so that
was enormously helpful and the the
tricky balance with girl on the train
and yet the thing I enjoyed about it is
that because it's a murder mystery
you're kind of playing two things you're
playing the reality of the character
right but you're also trying to pull the
will over the audience's eyes at the
same time so it's sort of a fun
challenge you know to be this unreliable
narrator but also be very truthful and
try and honor what this person's going
through you know it's it's it's a
masterful performance and I you were
nominated for a sag And a ba for that
for best actress and it was it was
astonishing to watch and and and and
once again
surprising and and and no vanity no not
for that
one which is pretty incredible um I
remember the um they had these contact
lenses that they made me for the really
really drunk scenes and it was a full
contact lens that covered the entirety
of your eye so that your whites of your
eyes would be
red that's that's my lasting memory of
going
was just like that all day um a quiet
place yes a quiet place can we just talk
about that scene we just all watched
that scene we just watched and behind
the camera is your
husband and you're having this child
without being able to make a sound I
just which is how I did it in real life
as well so that's why John wrote the
scene he like she can do that I mean I
just remember I was at the the premiere
and we were sitting in your row with all
your great friends and we literally were
all holding hands yeah at that moment I
remember because it was so hard to watch
and you played it so brutally honestly
as we see and it's just I mean how do
you go there m it is just do they say
okay now take two I mean what happens no
we shut it over the course of 5 days it
was a five-day birth you know we started
in the bedroom where the water breaks
and then gradually moved down to the
basement and you're holding on to that
for literally 5 days yeah it was I think
I had to be like institutionalized at
the end of that it was oh God did I
think John and I always laughed that
like we managed to get through quiet
place um on a lot of whiskey whiskey and
car rides listening to music together
you know and that was great but it was
just it was such a an I loved the chewy
challenge of it it was
so yes exhausting yeah but it was so
exhilarating and
um I just adored how John shot it and
like that's the other thing when you
work with your I mean you've worked with
John for years and with your John and
there's a comfort there's a comfort with
you guys but we'd never done it before
true so it's kind of scary cuz you're
sort of a different person when you're
at work yes and there was that moment
before we started filming where I was
like do you know how to shoot this movie
like
like I was like do you know what a lens
is cuz I I don't so I'm just like hoping
and and I just remember being so wowed
by him on the first day
and it was just like unrecognizable
other superpower that I hadn't seen it
was extraordinary and so I knew he was
going to shoot it in such an emotional
visceral raw way and he was so inspired
by Spielberg and Nolan and all of these
incredible Visionary guys and he shot it
in six weeks for $7 million we made that
movie and it was just none of us knew it
would become what it did but um yeah the
birth scene was it was wild it was
stunning and it's and and it's I I think
you
know I mean you won a sag award for that
that was so surprising not me not to me
well I was shocked not to me I
mean I mean it was sort of like well
because you're loved and people know and
people know that you're in your own
League we know everybody in this room
knows that's for sure this room knows
absolutely knows um there was a little
movie you did call Mary poppin return
tiny
little um let me just say I'll just say
this sort of very excuse the pun
bluntly um if it's something nice keep
it short it it's it's quick okay there
was no movie without you there was no
movie who's going to play this role who
can play this role I mean it's like
James Bond you know like there's like
one or two or three you know it's like
who's gonna play Mary Poppins who can
play that all the colors she's such a
rude person Mary Poppins I love that
about her she's so funny she does does
she just suffers no fools and she's
she's just and she's just way ahead of
everybody and she's just and and but
also so caring and loving underneath and
that you know you need a great actor to
play that part people think Mary Poppins
they don't understand this is a great
role and you knew that you knew that you
knew it's a great role was so scared it
was so scary and I'm sure scary for you
in many ways I mean I don't know if you
maybe name it as that because I think
you're so you're so powerful in your
tenacity at just creating that I think
maybe any fear just becomes white noise
to you or something something and and I
think you take everyone else's fear away
because of your conviction and that's so
exciting to be around and I remember you
and I talking a great deal about her and
how to carve out new space for ourselves
because the role is so iconic it was
played by somebody so iconic so it was
you never though made it feel to me like
I had this iconic Boulder I had to kind
of like move out of the way it was it
was not that way it was just just what
else can we do and we both read the
books a lot and in the books she's
horrible horrible to those kids I mean
she's unspeakably rude and she's not
very warm and fuzzy at all no and she's
weird yeah she's eccentric and on she
really batty and sort of like odd and we
loved it so I was like let's go there
like let's do that you did and you did
um you know even in the costumes I
remember Sandy and the great Sandy pal
she'd the coat would be blue but the
inside was this polka dot bright orange
and it was just such so emblematic of
the character like held together with um
you know this very precise Poise and
then underneath is this madness that she
just wants to unleash and do you
remember we decided that in the musical
numbers or in the adventures yes it was
her sense of relish yes that she
couldn't wait to do them like it
was so thrilling for her because she's a
child she lets that child out and she so
exciting and then so to play all those
colors and it was extraordinary I loved
her so much and your sag nomination your
Golden Globe nomination for that was
just beyond and and and and I just have
to say that the scene that you saw where
you where where she comes into to the
banks house for the first time um that
was the first scene we
rehearsed and um and I remember sitting
there I mean we had talked about it but
we hadn't put it on its feet we hadn't
really done it and um and we had great
actors there Ben Wishaw and Emily morer
and this wonderful children they were
just they're so spectacular and we said
well let's let's let's let's try this
and I'm and I thought oh this is you
know Emily's gonna walk in as Mary
Poppins
and you can't you walked through the
door our fake little door that we had
there on on the Sound Stage where we
were
wereing and there she
was like instantly there there was Mary
Poppins it was I mean it was I I cried
again I cried again because I couldn't
well I couldn't believe that you had
found it immediately it was not to me I
mean I was like I I was scared and like
Rob approached me um again I always seem
to associate pregnancy with Rob now but
um Rob had said to me I really want you
to be Mary Poppins and I was so honored
and so flawed and I said I just want you
to know JN and I really want to have
another baby and we sort of planning to
have one soon and he said okay I'll push
a few months you know did and so we
pushed and
um and so I remember and I always do
this on every movie really but
especially on something like Poppins
where it's such a I want to play someone
very
distinctive I will usually rent a a
house if I don't have any alone time at
home with the kids or with John there
I'll rent somewhere for like a few days
and I'll just walk around like a crazy
person talking to myself until something
lands and what I don't know how it
materializes but something will just
I'll find an in and I remember waddling
around nine months pregnant trying to
find how to play her you know and
feeling so and I remember being at the
first table read and it was the first
time I did the voice for you and I was
really scared it was so exciting to hear
I so scared and we had been talking
about rosn Russell we've been watching
his girl Friday it's so fast it's so
quick smart way she speaks at that
velocity like that she should come in
like a tornado and just sweep everything
up and make everything right again and
and and once again I I see that and I
say well there's the movie that's what I
see and I said you know and it's an
extraordinary performance and and and it
and it it is it is it is your
performance do you know what I mean it's
all yours it is Sensational in in
addition to everything else and all the
singing and all the dancing and all the
musicality of that plus that no one else
can do that it was such a joy BMB the
whole thing it was thrilling umill I
we're going to jump to Oppenheimer again
for a moment and and I we're going to
look at a clip from this um
extraordinary film uh Epic film um but
to me it all comes to a point after this
extraordinary journey to this moment and
um let's take a look at this
moment I hope they're
okay all
right this is this is a good one this is
a smart one what's a what's a common
Tech technique you use to get
emotionally ready for a
scene uh if it's a big heavy scene uh uh
music always I'll I'll listen to music
I'll
have uh depending on the film there'll
usually be like an album that will
represent the film like I remember
listening to like a lot of radio head on
sakaria like good but yes yes but
there'll be like anthems songs there
will be a song I'm in love with that I
will listen to on a
loop um as I'm walking to set and then
by the time I get to set I feel I'm in a
good Zone because one of the hardest
things as we know is the waiting yeah
the waiting and then you're and then
it's like wait but go so I just tried to
stay really Zen like really calm and
um yeah usually music so you're Olympian
that's what I mean um so now that you've
done a limited series and I'm thank you
for bringing this up the English which
was so thrilling talk about a whole
another genre thank you a western I mean
you're riding horses and you're killing
people and yeah I mean it was the most
beautiful experience that series I loved
it and it's an astonishing performance I
love it and and surprising and you
you're holding a secret the entire time
for a limited series so I'm sorry I'm
asking another question
but um is is television and this is a
great question limited series kind of
thing is that something else you'd like
to explore again in the future yeah and
why I mean well i' I'd been wanting to
do longform storytelling for so long
because it's it's that
Exquisite um lengthy Journey you can go
on with someone where you're gradually
peeling back all the all the layers
especially where there's a secret and a
mystery um I'd never had that experience
and the necessary stamina you need to
sort of get through it and a full
exploration of someone in their world
that doesn't feel that you're contorting
it to an hour and a half two hours and a
certain window you know so I mean when
the English came along I remember I read
the first page and fell completely in
love it's just so beautiful the most
rare poetic beautiful writing
relationship is so stunning yeah it was
so so wonderful and a whole another
genre and I'd never really done a
western you know I'd always want wanted
to that's what I mean the range is off
the charts um okay if you could be
friends with any of your previous
characters you've played who would be
your who and
why you know I would like to be friends
with the character in the English she is
the first one that comes to mind because
she I I've never admired a character so
much I just admired her so so much I
thought she was the best of every woman
she was
just had gone through so much grief and
so much trauma still chose to walk into
every day with this sense of hope and
kindness and empathy even though she'd
been shown none of that and it' been so
stripped of her identity I just loved
her probably her does it make in a way
it inspires you to become a better
person I guess if they live inside you
yes they kind of dwell in you and yeah
it's beautiful forget them you no well
we don't forget your performance in that
that's for sure and it's true I mean
it's I mean it's beyond she's gonna kill
me so your question will be followed by
a very wonderful compliment every time
she's she's literally when we go through
that door she going to kill me bar and
I'm going to slap you yeah there'll be a
full on SLAP um okay do you have a
preference of shooting the tough
emotional scenes early in production or
later when you've developed your
character later later later and why is
that just cuz they've lived in you you
you haven't got that sort of first day
first week jittery thing where I feel
like I'm slightly behind myself day one
like I have this feeling that I'm not
quite inside of myself you know and um I
think anytime you've got the full weight
of the experience and the trust of the
actors and the director like that's the
time where you can kind of tear it up a
bit in a big scene you know yeah that
makes perfect sense how do you how do
you best manage wearing multiple hats
because in terms of like for instance
producing and acting I feel like on the
English which is really my main
experience producing something is that I
felt
that it's in the pre-production I felt
like I was in
producer mode and then once I started
filming I didn't really feel that way I
felt like I had to fully commit to the
acting side of things I don't know it
it's partly because you know Hugo Blick
was at the helm of it and we had other
great producers there so I didn't have
to kind of bear the weight of it you
know and and when you're I mean and then
in post and so you're there in post yeah
are you objective about the work yes bet
I think I am actually and I think maybe
it's just come from being around the
block as long as I have been here I am
career retrospective I'm allowed to say
that oh my God there's so much more
coming but I think um I think I I'm so
interested in all the facets of it and
every Nuance of it and so I think I can
be objective afterwards yeah I I it's
sort of I disassociate from myself maybe
that's why I think you have that skill
big time um what specific things do you
look for when looking for a project what
are you looking
for I'm looking for great writing
a whole world it's not just about the
character or the circumstance I want to
see someone with a really specific
Vision that maybe transcends your
understanding of the world as you
thought you knew
it
that you want to feel that kind
of I feel like or is like an elusive
emotion I wish we could feel it more cuz
I think it really when you read that
script and you're left rather a struck
by it for whatever reason it could be a
mad comedy or it could be the English or
Marry Poppins it could be it could be
any but I want to feel
that
um life force crackling through me where
I don't really know like why I love it
and I can't name what it is about it and
sometimes you'll be given a script that
um you know I talk about with Chris all
the time like it's like the script won't
be there but it's the promise of it and
I can't let go of that the what I see it
could be right even if it's not there
fully it's the promise of the world to
come you know so you go with your gut
yeah and I I want a character with
conflict I want them to be hard to read
hard to name I want people in
circumstances where they H they're in
over their heads they are they're
confused they're
I I think I look for I look for conflict
you know so beautiful um so this is good
this is like a fullon like you better
lie down for this one because God how do
you deal with your inner
critic good
question um I just have Rob Marshall
around me all the
time and he just and the critic just
sort of waffs away just disappears um
I the critic will rear its head
sometimes of
course I feel I don't listen to that
critical voice other than
fleetingly I hope I can self-correct if
I do a doozy of a take which I do and
you you can feel when it's not working
and
I always try and have faith I'll get
there
um I accept that I'm going to throw a
lot at the wall to see what sticks it's
how I really like to work and sometimes
it could be the full spectrum of good or
crap but I I appreciate
the the journey I try I I I listen to
that voice but to try to make it better
maybe so beautiful them
um if you could portray any historical
figure you know I guess it's either dead
or alive I didn't say that but I'm just
gonna add that um who would that be is
there someone that that you is there
a historical character or or a person I
mean I
certainly well I mean I mean any woman
of strength I mean to me you know that
that because I mean I think
You' well I mean Nancy Pelosi
I yeah no I mean I just think listen any
any woman historical I mean you know
when you see young Victoria and you see
that you see the beginnings of her
career and you see who you know how she
has to handle you know well I think
maybe that's of Interest like playing
someone a woman at a time like we talked
about where women were being pretzel
contorted to be something that they
weren't where the odds were stacked
against them like those trailblazing
women in history that would be cool
exactly right yeah because then it's not
all easy for them it's not and then you
have the what you were discussing you
have the conflict yeah then you have the
fight yeah beautiful um what advice do
you have for female actors in coming up
in Hollywood I just have to say the
thing that made me laugh you know this I
told you this makes me laugh I just that
Betty Davis was asked that question what
did she say and she said this is what
she said take
fountain that was her advice for fale
actors take Fountain take Fountain so
true it's so true never Sunset guys um
never take uh so advice I mean it's it's
a broad question but is there I mean it
I'm not going to say anything as witty
as Betty DAV I take fun
um you know what it's
a just go right through it it's a it can
be hard it's not easy you got to wear a
helmet sometimes it's not always for the
faint of heart but put your feet to the
fire and go through it and if you have
passion and if you have conviction and
don't don't always listen to to your
agent or or anyone don't listen to
anyone don't listen to your friends or
your manager like do what you love go
towards that don't don't strategize
don't strategize your care it's so
brilliant it's don't think if I do this
it'll lead to this and this doesn't work
like that it doesn't work like that
it'll always be the most unexpected
turns and is it's it's it's just
about Instinct who do you want to play
who you interested in be curious and
don't watch don't watch too many
movies get out there see the world like
go to art galleries um read
extraordinary books Escape learn about
people be curious about people be
empathetic it's the ultimate form of
empathy and I mean don't watch too many
movies because then you may play
something that's derivative of something
you've seen or think you have to do
something you've seen in a movie it's
like stay curious stay empathetic it's
brilliant yeah and then take how
beautiful is that that's so
beautiful this is kind of a a beauty um
and maybe maybe one of our last ones
here because it's kind of joyous um it's
time for me to slap you I'm I'm gonna be
in such trouble I can't even tell
um how do you define
[Music]
success
because it's a it's loaded it's there's
so many there it's career but it's life
you know how do you find how do do you
find that for
yourself who asked
that oh you yes a very wise woman there
very wise
woman how do I define
success I'm sorry such a pregnant
pause um
we'll we'll fix it in
[Laughter]
post I think
um it's it's not cliched it's
fulfillment like if you feel fulfilled
within yourself um it doesn't have to be
defined as something you don't have to
have an opulent life you don't have to
have a
yacht if you are fulfilled if you wake
up every day day seeking a sense of awe
and
wonder I think you have success I think
that if you lack stagnancy in your
life if you feel that sense of like
effervescent
aliveness and if you love what you do
then you're
successful oh my
God that's why you are who you are can I
just say right now this is an
extraordinary woman on every level but
thank you for everything this was so
beautiful ladies and gentlemen the
extraordinary Emily Blunt thank you very
very much thank you for all of
[Applause]
[Music]
that